we all know what it takes to become an
nba player years of countless practices
camps and games
those who make it to the nba usually
start playing basketball from a very
young age they develop a skill set based
around shooting ball handling passing
defense and anything else that brings
one success in basketball but what are
the chances of becoming an nba player
well they are remarkably low think about
it there are 30 teams of about 15
players each for a total of roughly 450
players
now there are estimates that there are
more than five hundred thousand young
men playing youth basketball around the
country
when you crunch the numbers you will
realize that fewer than one in a
thousand will make it to the nba
the same can be concluded pretty much
about any other popular sport such as
american football european soccer
baseball and tennis
so let's be realistic
you're not going to make it to the nba
you will not become the president of the
united states you will not be the
world's greatest writer nor the top
chess player nor the most masterful
public speaker you will never be the
best in the world at any given skill
there will always be someone working
harder
there will always be someone with
greater genetic gifts or more luck or
both
but trying to be the best at one thing
is not the smartest path to success
instead you should put your effort into
mastering a combination of skills
the solution is skill stacking a concept
popularized by scott adams here's how it
works
years ago a friend of mine had to take
the gmat test it was hoping to get into
some of the top graduate business
schools and nailing this test was a key
step in the process his first choice
school stanford would only accept the
top six percent of applicants that meant
he had a score in the 94th percentile to
have a shot at getting in
the day of the test he was trembling he
sat in front of his computer in the test
room looking at the clock one minute
left to start 20 seconds one
begin
after four intense hours he finished the
test but he couldn't rest because the
results appeared almost instantly on the
screen
he scored in the 90th percentile on the
math portion
and in the 95th percentile on the verbal
portion
so that means i'm in the 92nd percentile
he thought his heart sank
those scores wouldn't cut it goodbye
stanford but then as he looked closer he
saw something else his overall score was
in the 98th percentile what
how was this possible
it turns out most math-minded test
takers were bad with words and the
word-loving ones couldn't quite hack the
fractions so while my friend's score
wasn't the best in any one section it
was among the best when these sections
were considered in combination
this is how skill stacking works it's
easier and more effective to be in the
top 10 in several different skills which
together form your own skill stack than
it is to be in the top one percent in
any one skill
ideally the skills should be unique and
also complementary
imagine someone who is reasonably good
at public speaking fundraising speech
writing charisma networking social media
and persuasion who is this person
a successful politician
the most successful politicians don't
seem to be off the charts amazing at
individual skills but check off the
right boxes that allow them to thrive at
their craft
this principle applies across all fields
a writer can be just about the best
prose stylist there is but probably
won't find as much success as the person
who is a reasonably good prose stylist a
strong self-promoter a pretty fast
writer and engaging public speaker and
has the interpersonal skills to connect
with important people in the publishing
industry
self-help eurodairy vaynerchuk is a
great example of a skill stacker
he has almost 10 million instagram and
tick tock followers over 2 million
twitter followers over 3 million youtube
subscribers and an active blog that
people read as if it were holy scripture
on these channels you'll find content
that is solid but not exactly
mind-blowing the magic that sets
vaynerchuk apart is his skill stack the
fact that he's not just a good writer
but is also savvy on social media good
at public speaking and great at personal
branding is what makes him one of the
top self-help gurus in his field the
same principle applies to steve jobs too
at the heart of jobs skills stack is a
passion for design be it fonts packaging
or architecture
he was obsessive about the look and feel
of his products he was never the best in
the world at design but over time he
developed a keen understanding of
winning design principles he later
combined his various design skills with
deep insight about what people want
technical knowledge a strategic mind
salesmanship and ability to extract
everything from his employees and
entrepreneurial skills
together these skills helped him form a
company that was focused on advanced
technology and beautiful design
in discovering your own skill stack
consider the combination of skills
you want them to be related in some way
but not too similar
for example if you are in the top one
percent in programming also being in the
top one percent in writing automated
tests isn't going to be a big
differentiator most top programmers are
good test writers what is different
about stacking is having skills that not
only work together but also are varied
enough to make you stand out
the best skills to choose are those that
don't tend to go together but complement
each other well for example programmers
aren't known to be great public speakers
so those who are will have a huge
professional advantage think about it if
you are a top programmer who can develop
complementary skills of design
psychology public speaking
entrepreneurship you will be a great
candidate to become the founder of the
next multi-billion software startup
you'll have the right skills to select
the best tech for your product work with
a design team to make it truly stand out
and influence others in order to attract
vc funding into your start-up as well as
hire the best talent on the market your
individual skills with your individual
level against the rest of population
might look like these on the chart but
when you combine them together you can
identify the overlapping area even if
you are not in the top one percent in
any of these skills very few people
overlapping all of them
stop trying to be the best at one thing
you're setting yourself up for some
serious disappointment
instead ask yourself
in what niche do i want to stand out
what combination of skills do i need to
be unique in that niche
am i passionate about most of these
skills
it is not about being great at any one
thing you just need to be pretty good at
an array of useful skills
when combined these skills will make you
truly one of a kind
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button also make sure to subscribe to
the coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell
enjoy the rest of your day